georg friedrich hegel
was born in Stuttgart in 1770
intellectually he was adventurous but in
externals respectable conventional and
proud of it he assented the academic
tree and reached the topmost branch head
of the University of Berlin when he was
60 years old he died the following year
Hegel wrote some very long and very
famous books among them the
phenomenology of spirit the science of
logic and elements of the philosophy of
right but will be frank
he wrote horribly his work is confusing
and complicated when it should be clear
and direct he tapped into a weakness of
human nature to be trustful of grave
sounding incomprehensible prose this has
made philosophy much weaker in the world
than it should be
and it's made it much harder for us to
hear the valuable things that Hegel has
to say to us amongst which a small
number of lessons stand out firstly
important parts of ourselves can be
found in history in Hegel stay a
standard European way of looking at the
past was to consider it as primitive and
to feel proud of how much progress had
been made to get us to the modern age
but in his book the phenomenology of
spirit published in 1807 Hegel argued
that every era can be looked at as a
repository of a particular kind of
wisdom this means we need to go back in
time to rescue things which have gone
missing so for example we might need to
mine the history of ancient Greece to
fully grasp the idea of what community
can be something which has been lost in
the modern age or the Middle Ages can
teach us as no other era can about the
role of Honor even if this period
featured appalling attitudes to children
or the rights of women progress is never
linear Hegel tells us there is wisdom at
every stage which says Hegel points us
to the task of the historian to be a
historian is to be someone who should
rescue from the past those ideas that
are most needed to compensate for the
blind spots of the present secondly
learn from ideas you dislike Hegel was a
great believer
learning from one's intellectual enemies
from points of view we disagree with all
that feel alien that's because he held
the bits of the truth are always getting
scattered even in unappealing or
peculiar places and we should dig them
out by asking always what sliver of
sense and reason might be contained in
otherwise frightening or foreign
phenomena nationalism for instance has
had many terrible manifestations even in
Hegel's day but Hegel's move was to ask
what underlying good idea or important
need might be hiding within the bloody
history of nationalism he proposed that
it's the need for people to feel proud
of where they come from to identify with
something beyond merely their own
achievements and to anchor their
identities beyond the ego Hegel is a
hero of the thought that really
important ideas may be in the hands of
people you regard at first glance as
beneath contempt thirdly progress is
messy Hegel believed that the world
makes progress but only by lurching from
one extreme to another as it seeks to
overcompensate for a previous mistake he
proposed that it generally takes three
moves before the right balance on any
issue can be found a process that he
named that dialectic he was often
thinking of the complex twists and turns
that brought about the modern state we
can also think of the slow path towards
sensible attitudes to sex in our own
time the Victorians imposed too much
repression yet the 1960s may have turned
out to be too liberal it might only be
by the 2020s that will find the right
balance between extremes all this can
seem the most appalling waste of time
but Hegel insists that the painful
stepping from error to error is
inevitable something we must expect and
reconcile ourselves to when planning our
lives or contemplating history books and
sometimes in this process of moving from
error to error we will find a new
solution that manages to synthesize the
good qualities of the previous solutions
to make something really new and
different and better for art as
Epis Hagel vigorously rejected the idea
of art for art's sake painting music
architecture literature and design all
have a major job to do we need them so
that important insights can become
powerful and helpful in our lives art is
in Hegel's formulation the sensuous
presentation of ideas
just knowing ideas often leaves us cold
for example in theory we believe that
conflict in Syria is an important one in
practice however we just switch off in
principle we know we should be more
forgiving to our partners but this
abstract conviction gets forgotten at
the least provocation the point of art
Hegel realized is not so much to come up
with startlingly new or strange ideas
but to take the good helpful important
thoughts we already think we know and
make them stick more imaginatively in
our minds 5 we need new institutions
Hegel took a very positive view of
institutions and of the power they can
wield this was a point Hegel made again
and again in different ways for ideas to
be active and effective in the world a
lot more is needed than that ideas are
simply correct to make major truths
powerful in society they need employees
and buildings and budgets and legal
advisors institutions allow for the
scale of time and power that big
projects need to become effective in the
world
so as new needs of a society get
recognized they should ideally lead not
just to new books but to the formation
of new institutions nowadays we might
say we need major new institutions to
focus on relationships consumer
education career choice mood management
and how to bring up less damaged
children Hegel helps us to see valuable
insights where we might initially resist
them in art institutions in the ideas of
our enemies and in the strange mistakes
of the past his insight is that growth
requires the clash of divergent ideas
and therefore that it will be painful
and slow but at least once we know this
we don't have to compound our troubles
by thinking them abnormal Hegel gives us
a more accurate and hence more
manageable view of ourselves our
difficulties and
we are in history
you